como ven ambiente de celebración total
aquí en Marruecos tras la victoria de la
selección nacional que se han puesto
junto con dos goles contra Bélgica dos
goles de sabinillas ahora todas las
expectativas están puestas en el partido
de la semana próxima elección se
preparará contra Canadá y a destacar es
la victoria es muy importante y muy
simbólica aquí en Marruecos porque desde
hace 24 años la selección no ganamos
partidos
estamos muy muy felices viva Marruecos
siempre Marruecos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
somos seguidores de la selección estamos
muy contentos siempre sabiri que viva
saviri Oye oye vas a saber
[Aplausos]
gracias a nuestros jugadores estamos muy
orgullosos de ustedes por haber ganado
han ganado
ya viene Canadá vamos a ganarle a Canadá
[Aplausos]